turn if I publicly ashamed right my mood
can't like what happened in Nashville oh
no that's right I was in Nashville
eating at a BBQ BBQ restaurant okay and
I have jeans and a little bit my ass
crack showing okay just a little bit
okay I mean it's like my butthole
hanging out right and I'm soon there
eating on this high stool on this big
table and I'm eating my little barbecue
I'm in Nashville and this man puts his
armor on me he has a black jacket on
he's probably 52 53 years old and he's
with his kids and wife like I yeah
southern guy and he puts his hand around
me and he goes son pull your pants up
you know what I did I'm sorry like a
[ __ ] okay sorry like that's so weird
it was imagine in Nashville everybody's
ass cracking hold it up and he left I
literally went into like like a
self-hatred
yeah I hate your thing because what I
should have said is no this is [ __ ]
America [ __ ] those aren't my kids you
have eyes look away my buttholes gonna
hang out I don't think that's the answer
either see the kids you know in all
honesty I would have been I would have
reacted the same way as you like oh I'm
sorry and I would have yeah but why hate
confrontation yeah but why do are we
sorry why do we say that I think as
quickly as possible yeah yeah but the
fastest way is by saying sorry and doing
it but I think like I would imagine like
if I were watching a movie I would want
the main character to be like I will
pull up my pants but you don't have to
talk to me like that I can never see my
holistic doctor yeah okay
you would have the right answer I you
know what I don't think that quickly on
my feet in situations like that in
public
death eyes come on like ideally what
would like the perfect person say I I I
would probably try and reason with him I
would probably I'm gonna say something
I'm the guy okay excuse me miss pull
your pants up please for what
we're buttholes hanging out my kids are
what no you know what that's not what I
would say honestly my true reaction
would be like Bobby's I always apologize
yeah before I even because yes Nick and
we let white people tell us what to do
but I I don't think it's so I don't
think it's a race thing I think if an
Asian person said that's why I would
probably even be more apologetic but
they wouldn't know I was fight an Asian
person but they wouldn't say anything
yeah you know you're right because if it
was an issue so that you'd fight them
okay dad fan comes up to you hey Bobby
your butthole showing how are your TV
shows and movies that you're doing right
now
no I it's it's I feel like Asians
wouldn't say because I've been in Korean
restaurants looking like a whole ball
yeah you know why Asians wouldn't say it
because you shouldn't [ __ ] say
anything I know that's what I'm saying
only white people have this thing when
they see an ethnic person now I'm gonna
go tell this young man what to do with
his life I definitely don't like the way
he said it I think it was like really
condescending he clutch you that's why
my perfect person would say you don't
need to talk to me like that okay that's
it you're right that right there is the
best day Thanks all right we asked up a
CIA
[Music]